recently our Matthew our Tech wizard got
hold of the quantum mirror app and he
got to speak very briefly to evil J and
I desperately wanted to interview him a
little bit further and find out what
Stargate in the Mirror Universe is
really like welcome to SRA your CI TV
and movie
channel
[Music]
so I generally don't know how this is
going to go because the last time we
spoke to Mirror Universe evil Jay he
told us he really likes kicking babies
and that Canadians are the most violent
hateful people on the planet and he
loves them for it so I'm dreading asking
him the question what is Stargate sg1
like in the Mirror Universe because I
have literally no idea idea what he's
going to say
but let's get into it and find
out miror Universe J is is that you are
you with us what do you want and and why
haven't you got a goatee I mean you look
like a complete idiot so I wanted to
talk to you about Stargate sg1 I assume
that's still a show over there is it a
show you like
yes of course Stargate is still my
favorite show it's the greatest show
ever made why wouldn't it be well thank
the gods at least that's the same so
I've got a a few questions for you let's
try and thrash this out what is star G
about in the Mirror Universe I'm
wondering if it's the same sort of
premise basically dumass about team that
goes through a square Stargate that go
off and battle good
they find benevolent kind sweet gods and
they kill them in the most brutal
fashion
possible sometimes you know they blow up
their planets they you know Slaughter
innocent children they basically do
everything they can to make the sweet
sickly Gods lives in absolute misery
that's just a great show
really
oh God that's that's not what our
Stargates about at
all no no it's the the gold old are evil
they're the ones that are sort of trying
to take over the Galaxy and there's like
a snake in the back of their heads and
you know their eyes glow whenever
they're um you know doing something
particularly evil in sg1 the gold W are
fluffy and lovely and I mean they help
everyone they can and they protect
people for like no reason and don't even
ask for anything in return you know they
help someone they don't even want pain
they're completely useless honestly
they're like wise
and no don't like them but but they
sound really nice that's more like the
Asgard the Asgard is psychos what you on
about oh they're vicious they regularly
kidnap people from their beds and do
like weird experiments and like like to
like shove things up there you know wooo
the asard a properly terrifying I kind
of like them to be honest they're a bit
like
Canadians okay this show really is um
it's it's a little bit different isn't
it but are any of the characters the
same I mean Jack O'Neal sarcastic funny
love Sam but can never tell her no
O'Neal's is boring as hell God no the
actor they've got to play him is the
most dull person you will ever meet in
monotone voice and no never cracks a
smile he's a proper like Soldier sort of
thing never takes oh takes everything
way way too seriously it's just oh it's
the most irritating character yeah
generally people hate him but you know
it gets the story going I suppose and
him and Sam go at it constantly I mean
they're all like dressed in leather and
like whips and and me it gets
pretty x-rated you know a lot of the
time they do not hide it in fact they
flaunt it
regularly
what it's kind of kind of sexy to be
honest there was this one time that um
Sam and anneal wrapped themselves in
like this American flag and just went at
it for like three quarters of the
episode it was
awesome okay well I mean how about
Daniel Jackson in in our version he's
he's a linguist he's really wise he's
thoughtful I mean he ascends several
times he's probably one of the most
intelligent characters in the show to be
honest
Daniel God he just can't die they keep
getting him in the most ridiculous like
situations where he should 100% die
horribly and he just keep
surviving and I don't know what you on
about linguist a man can barely speak
English he he is an awesome Canadian
though I mean he just goes in and just
punches people Square in the face
instead of saying hello he really really
doesn't say much re you know if I think
about it he doesn't really
speak no pretty much just punches people
in the face might be my favorite
character right okay um
wow okay well teal he can't be any
different
surely teal cracks me up he's always
telling jokes he's always giggling he's
always you know seeing the light side in
things he is funny and when people die
horribly he's there always there like
the one liner oh he cracks me up he's
the best I can't even begin to imagine
that he smiles I
mean
wow that's that's a little creepy okay
Sam Sam Carter okay fair enough she's
getting it on with O'Neal every chance
she gets but she's still intelligent I
mean because she's the one that mgy had
the Stargate so she's got to be a genius
still right Carter in your show she's
the one that sort of got the gate
working Jesus in this show she's a
honestly she tried to go through
the gate the wrong way once you know
like from like right in the back don't
even know what she was thinking there
and she regularly gets lost in the base
you know there's whole episodes where
it's like where's Sam don't know got
lost in the base
again yeah no she's she's an
idiot she SS like a complete
dumbass she sounds like the sort of
person that couldn't even open a door
that hitting herself in the face with it
I don't know about that but she has Set
Fire to the base once or twice cooking
toast please God at least tell me
Hammond of Texas is still in it and is
still just as
awesome what pretty boy Hammond with all
the hair no he left years ago he does
L'Oreal adverts now okay but how about
some of the classic episodes we can't go
wrong with that I mean window of
opportunity it's it's the best episode
ever made right no window opportunity is
a great episode it won loads of awards
they changed the rules for um like the
Oscar so that it could win best actor um
serious I mean I nearly cried it's you
know it's a really heartfelt episode oh
you know yeah I that it's one of the
best episodes not a laugh a minute but
God it's a good episode yeah no
seriously won loads of awards it's still
it's still a good episode really
properly dramatic stuff that no
brilliant episode still a brilliant
episode I gotta be honest with you
though evil J this show sounds awful
why' you even watch it mindless violence
and good getting its ass kicked what
isn't to Love No it's it's one of the
greatest shows ever made if not the
greatest show ever
made oh yeah of course
evil well look mate thanks so much for
you know getting in touch and saying
hello
see you again sometime yeah yeah
whatever um I hope you and your family
die in a horrible burning accident and
you know that basically no one cares
when it
happens okay thanks
[Music]
bye